si es una situación dramática aquí en la
frontera está estos tres joyeros que se
pueden ver detrás decir que el juego
está refugiado acaban de llegar aquí en
polonia y acaban de llegar después de
días de esperanza y esperar de esperar
detrás de la frontera en el lado o cada
verano
y eso es eso entre esta gente son
mujeres y niños
muy jóvenes que los hombres deben
quedarse en ucrania o cocaína para
luchar
detrás de la frontera hay mucho mucho
tráfico
líneas de 50 kilómetros al lado
ucraniano y he visto esta mañana algo
muy muy fuerte he visto a un oso
craneanos que viven aquí
en polonia y que se vuelven a no caer en
ocarina para luchar y saben
perfectamente
qué peligroso es pero han decidido que
fue lo correcto de hacer eso y fue muy
emocionante y emocionante
tdt llegará a eso esta mañana y también
aquí en cdn a nadie la ayuda humanitaria
acabo de organizarse hay muchos
voluntarios muchos voluntarios
aquí también
acaban justo de organizarse es una
situación muy nueva también por polonia
y polonia muestra un gran solidaridad
las escuelas son requisición hadas para
o como como lados de emergencia de
fobias y emergencias o donde entonces
una grande ayuda del de polonia también
de la unión europa en europa aquí en la
frontera bueno y en medio de esta
situación el alto comisionado para los
refugiados de la onu denunció que se
están presentando casos de
discriminación en la frontera a qué se
refiere puntualmente
pues la primera discriminación a la
frontera ucraniana es la de las tres
líneas una para las mujeres y los niños
una otra con los hombres y los hombres
deben quedarse en el país para luchar y
una otra y una otra línea para los
extranjeros y uno de géneros mí
me dicen que es complicado cuando
extranjeros viene fue por ejemplo de
áfrica o de asia de pasar esa frontera
pero las complicaciones las dificultades
vienen del lado cambiado es complicado
de tomar el tren de de tomar un bus
hasta la frontera pero aquí en polonia y
también el gobierno polaco
dice eso todos los ateneos son
bienvenidos en esa situación excepcional
en esa situación de urgencia